Brethren the evidence is Supernatural
dude the evidence that this is the
actual shroud of our Lord and the images
of Our Lord is so overwhelming you
really are hardened and blind to deny it
so go watch it and now another video
dropped with ro Father Richard Spitzer I
didn't watch it I saw it where he says
the shout is authentic it just came out
I'll get you the link but here's the
clip I want to play from the 13 minute 4
second Mark go watch it you will be
blown away like dude come on man the gig
is up this is a miraculous artifact
preserved and then he describes that the
radiation blast the radiation blast that
would have left that image that ultral
light he goes that was caused by
radiation and he says something
mind-blowing in this video Gary
habberman says you can actually see the
teeth the teeth of the individual now
why is that important because he says
the reason why the teeth of the
individual means his mouth started
opening up now what would cause his
mouth to open but that Blast Of Glorious
light that would have animated the body
of Our Lord in other words if you've
ever seen so imagine and as he's coming
to life his mouth is opening he goes you
can actually now see the teeth from the
individual's mouth opening now why even
though Rigamortis had set in because
when our lord Jesus entered his body and
animated it that glorious blast of his
Divine Light his mouth open and left an
imprint of his mouth opening where you
see the teeth yeah it's in the video I'm
not lying but here's another thing you
may not be aware of and I mentioned it
previously yet father is it robt or
Richard Spitzer are you sure it's Robert
Spitzer see I'm telling you I suck with
names God correct me on the spot destroy
my error it's Richard Spitzer dude and
use to Center
anyway you see on the photograph holes
look what he says in
1340 right here let me see here watch
here get ready get ready right here
look there's some issues there uh how
come we don't have any why don't then
why don't have any body images on the
other hundreds of bar cloths that we
have why only this one okay another one
he's got something pressed down on his
scalp hear that's made wounds all the
way through his scalp why do you put
something like Thorns do you hear it I
would even say Crown that's a little bit
prejudiced I can just see the thorn
holes see why would you put that on a
criminal did you hear
it the image shows that the man has
holes in his skull
well if this is Jesus then the crown of
thorns would have pierced open his head
do you hear it it's right there
watch I mean just a few years after his
death thousands of Jews are crucified in
Jerusalem what about somebody else well
there's some issues there uh how come we
don't have any why don't then why don't
we have any body images on the other
hundreds of barrier cloths that we have
why only this one okay another one
he's got something pressed down on his
scalp that's made wounds all the way
through his scalp why do you put
something like
Thorns I would even say Crown that's a
little bit prejudiced I can just see the
thorn holes why would you put that on
the criminal oh because they thought he
was claiming to be the Messiah ah now
you're cheating if they crucified him in
Jerusalem there's nobody there who
thinks he's the Messiah that they're
putting up there putting a crown of
thorns on so why this guy why does he
have what things that were done to Jesus
were not normal crucifixion procedure uh
you might for example
argue um by the way Josephus argues that
even people capital punishment were
given individual burials because the
Jews valued the body but you might argue
that they would throw crucified bodies
in the trash sheep in the burning
smoldering trash sheep in Jerusalem why
was Jesus buried individually in a in a
beautiful cloth Y in a rich man's tomb
well how do you know it was a rich man's
tomb well there's not dirt all over the
thing he was in a in a atmosphere where
you know he's you know he's buried in a
in a tomb that's what you have when the
the cloth is in such good shape he
wasn't thrown in the ground and
decomposed I mean the the cloth
decomposed hear it the cloth is in such
good shape that means this is not the
burial cloth of some criminal thrown in
a pit because then there would be dirt
and debris and would Decay debris now
this cloth is in fine condition which
makes sense if this is the barrel cloth
of our Lord and was put in a tomb anyway
this is just some of the evidence
overwhelming but no no it's not it's
it's just the hoax yeah
so you have on the head of this
individual holes wounds made by
something which perfectly coincides with
the crown of thorns that Jesus had
placed on his head but n and then other
things he shows you Rigamortis sets in
and the position of the body shows that
Rigamortis set in because his knee is
bent and his body is curved when the
body
stiffens right and look at the imagery
they only saw this when they
photographed it and the man saw the
negatives of it because when you see
it just a cloth it's very dim but when a
man took a photograph and looked at the
negatives this is what
showed it only shows as a
negative negative the back side because
the way it's folded it covered his back
and front and you see in the back here
you see these holes that is perfectly
compatible with someone who's been
whipped in the
back right here
whipped and they also saw a mark a mark
on his side like it's been pierced open
all of this on this man but no come on
man no
way no man this is this is a hoax here's
another living Reckless artifact
preserved by our Lord only the most
hardened demonized Skeptics will deny
look you see these they'll tell you yes
these are marks on the body on the back
which perfectly comports with Jesus
being whipped you see it right here
right here even
see you see it and even here this from
what I remember that shows a hole
because this is why you see it's lit
because it's like the blood from the
hole that and he says it's consistent
with blood and water that's what he says
in interview but no it's not it's not
Jesus's no no no it's not now let me get
you the link to Robert
Spitzer the shot of turn is real all the
evidence with Father Robert J Spitzer
two days ago he's going to give you the
massive evidence showing it is real Eat
Your Heart Out atheist sucks being being
you sucks being you so here it is here's
the
link there it goes I'm going to watch it
myself Lord willing but I just want to
share it with you another living
miraculous artifact that Jesus is alive
he's risen God is real
folks death is not the end of us folks
the Lord lives he's alive it's over
folks see the light of the resur the the
light of the Resurrection The Miraculous
shot of turn he talks about that light
was made by a radiation blast in fact
full armor he told you that in the
interview you did with him right that
that kind of Imaging would have been
made by a radiation blast a blast of
radiation a light that is the Creative
Energy that energizing light that comes
from Christ who gives life to the world
that's John 1:4 in him was life and that
life was the light of men
right so there you go so go there and
watch it you got it I think there was
something else I want to yep that is
correct see in an interview he tells him
that you can type in what he said and
I'll put it on the
screen yep exactly that's not dude it's
a miracle man I mean give it up give it
up it's
real
Islam the massive historical
archaeological
textual scientific medical facts show
God is real the god of the Bible is real
the god revealing Jesus is real and now
the Shroud shows you Jesus died rose
again he's alive he's God In the Flesh
it's over by by Islam you're a joke by
by Unitarianism it's over Jesus is Lord
he lives our faith is
true and yeah even in an interview with
Gary habas and David would have tell you
we do not have the technology to
replicate ated even with today's
technology we can't replicate that image
it's there they can't they we can't do
it we're we're not at that level with
our technology to replicate that kind of
image but no it's it's it's it was a
great yeah yeah it's it's a forgery